We do have, I guess, what we're calling good
news regarding the Johnson and Johnson vaccine.
Dr. Anthony Fauci says that he believes the
U.S. is going to resume use of the Johnson
and Johnson vaccine for coronavirus by the
end of the week, maybe with some kind of warning
or restriction attached.
You might remember we covered last Tuesday
that regulators said temporarily pause use
of the single dose Johnson and Johnson vaccine.
There were six cases of rare brain blood clots,
all in women age 18 to 48.
I believe as of right now that one of those
women died.
This is out of about seven million Johnson
and Johnson vaccine doses that were given.
And Dr. Fauci says he's expecting a decision
on that vaccine maybe by this Friday, and
that the most likely outcome, he seems confident
that there will be a resumption of the use
of that vaccine.
You will again remember that this was within
13 days of receiving the shot women age 18
to 48 who developed these symptoms.
The FDA decided to put a pause out of, quote,
an abundance of caution.
And unfortunately, you know, this is one of
those things that what's tough about it is
that it will create certainly some additional
anti VAX sentiment and provide fuel for the
anti vaccine crowd, even if it is not warranted.
And it's one of these things where you really
have to think of the numbers.
Big picture, that vaccine has been given to
more than seven million people.
There have been six or seven blood clots reported
and one of those people died.
And when you first of all, when you compare
that to the death rate of getting the virus
itself, that's important context to have and
to provide.
The other reality is, you know, if if you
wanted to be really careful with this and
this is, I think, what Dr. Fauci is kind of
alluding to or maybe what's being considered
by regulators, it was all women, 18 to 48.
What if you say, well, maybe you don't give
this vaccine to women 18 to 48?
The other factor, and I mentioned this last
week and there's some early suggestions, but
it's still being investigated that there may
be a medicine interaction that is common to
the individuals that experience this, the
six or seven women that experience the blood
clotting.
If it were determined that there's a specific
interaction between a medication that these
women were on and the vaccine, that would
even be further reassuring, you could figure
out exactly who it is that should not receive
this vaccine.
And that's something that is increasingly
being looked at.
There was a bit of a slowdown over the weekend
in terms of vaccine doses.
And in fact, I'm pulling up the numbers myself,
although it's not clear that it's related
to the Johnson and Johnson decision.
If you look at the numbers from over the weekend,
there was a bit of a slowdown in the number
of doses given there are reports that this
may be because of what's called demand slackening
a little bit.
There was just a little bit of a downturn.
If you go back to about April 11th and look
at the last eight days, the average number
of doses has gone down.
Now, part of it reasonably would be because
of the JNJ pause.
But there are reports that some states, states
where there's less interest in the vaccine,
places like the example we've been looking
at is Mississippi, where we may actually be
at the point where there is more supply and
ability to give the vaccine than there is
demand.
And what's going to have to be figured out
is will vaccine start to be shifted from states
where there is less demand to states where
there is more demand of, I believe, Vermont
and Massachusetts, both at the top with 92
percent of the population wanting the vaccine?
Is that even possible?
Is it a recipe for disaster starting to move
vaccines around instead?
Will will the focus be just on a campaign
to make people want the vaccine?
Yesterday, we saw Joe Biden and Barack Obama
participate in an event talking about the
vaccine, encouraging people to get it.
I don't know the answer, but it seems as though
today, which is the day where everybody becomes
eligible, we are starting to see a slackening
of demand.
Hopefully full eligibility starting today
will bring a bunch of new demand and maybe
we can get up to even four million doses a
day.
Remains to be seen.
JNJ, though, expected to come back online,
possibly as soon as Friday.